welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and loki forces the god of mischief
to pay for his crime of violating the
sacred timeline but
why is loki being held accountable while
other more heinous marvel time meddlers
like the avengers and thanos
are getting off scotland free and thanks
to kiwico for sponsoring today's video
more about them in a bit i mean not to
be a snitch who whines josh skipped
school too
actually i never had the guts to skip i
spent senior skip day learning about
schrodinger but
i think we all felt loki's
alarm when he rightly pointed out that
he
only came into possession of the
tesseract because the avengers traveled
through time first
only to be told by tva justice renslayer
what they did was supposed to happen
you escaping was not yeah a slap in the
face worse than that wobble mouth he got
in mongolia so is the tva
rigged are they all hypocrites i think
the answer to those questions tells us
why
loki is really stuck with the tva as
well as marvel's plans to set up its
broader multiverse and how exactly loki
is explaining the leftover timelines
created by cap and thanos in avengers
endgame so remember in endgame the
avengers used time travel to steal the
infinity stones but they
obeyed the ancient one's warnings to
restore the sacred timeline by returning
the stones but during that time heist
loki stole the space stone and used it
to teleport to mongolia
creating the timeline that captain
america by returning the stones never
truly pruned
and despite not at all pestering the
avengers within minutes the tva arrested
loki
the thing is loki wasn't the only loose
end variant coming out of end game
because also during the time heist 2014
era thanos jumped forward in time to the
present
leaving a timeline without himself or
his forces
similarly steve rogers created a branch
timeline by
staying with peggy carter in the 1940s
at least according to the directors
unlike the screenwriters who say that
old steve actually lived in the
background of the same timeline history
that we've been watching
and if you think about it doing nothing
to help his best friend bucky while he
was being tortured by hydra for decades
or help the avengers
or prevent jfk's assassination or 911 i
guess he was just chilling with the
eternals but
loki's updated logic seems to suggest
that thanos and cap did not create new
branch timelines
that except for loki everything that
happened in endgame left the sacred
timeline
intact even if it means old steve lived
his life in that sacred timeline and
never slept today in his life over all
the atrocities he let happen but not
only that
renslayer says everything the avengers
did was supposed to happen
so why does the tva have this double
standard for loki well i have three
theories
theory one is that maybe the tba does
prosecute thanos and steve rogers but we
just didn't see those trials
and thanos and steve had better defenses
than loki did in the comics thanos is
brought to
trial before the universe's ultimate
judge the living tribunal who found
thanos not guilty for snapping away half
of all life
arguing that he didn't really break any
natural laws the screenwriters even
revealed that they wrote a version of
the scene that got removed from the
movie
and so we stuck the living tribunal in
the movie
as thanos and doctor strange
came to blows doctor strange blew thanos
mind and sent him through the mindscape
and if you listen closely in this loki
episode mobia seems to suggest that
there is another cosmic authority that
judges between right and wrong oh so
that had the timekeepers seal of
approval did it
well i wouldn't think of it in terms of
approval and disapproval that's sort of
a
let's get back to escapes approval and
disapproval
would be the jurisdiction of the living
tribunal and thanos could have appealed
beyond the tba to this higher authority
to get a ruling in his favor and when it
comes to steve rogers if the loki series
ends up supporting the endgame
director's interpretation that steve
did create a new branch timeline with
peggy in loki episode 1 there is one
background variant detainee that looks a
lot like peggy now i'm not sure if it's
her but if it is
she might be getting arrested as a
timeline violator or really maybe
brought in as a witness for steve's
trial at which point i could imagine
captain america charming the pants off
the tva
and arguing that he was already removed
from his destined path when he was
frozen
and now after his mission is complete
and he pruned every branch like they
promised they would
he deserves to restore his original life
path but if you don't buy that
theory two is that the tva may genuinely
consider the time heist
and thanos and steve rogers to just be
part of the sacred timeline but
genuinely believe loki is not part of it
like it may just be as simple as the
timekeepers dictating that within this
sacred timeline will be a little wobble
involving a sloppy time heist that will
all sort itself out at the end
because it is destiny for the avengers
to bring everyone back it's destiny for
thanos to die
destiny for tony stark to die for cap to
end up in the past and that
is why out of 14 605 different outcomes
doctor strange
could only see one victorious future and
that loki escaping was just not part of
that plan
i mean really we can consider this the
kevin feige is the one above all
explanation and things just play out the
way they do because marvel studios
decided that would make for the most
interesting stories
and that it's just more thematically
satisfying to see loki have to deal with
illogical unfair universal law
and thanks again to kiwico for
sponsoring today's video kiwiko is
defining the future of play by making it
engaging enriching and seriously fun
they create cool hands-on projects and
toys designed to expose kids to concepts
in steam science technology engineering
art and math
each monthly crate is designed by
experts tested by kids and teaches a new
theme through hands-on learning and fun
they believe in the concept of small
today big tomorrow
they teach kids problem solving on small
projects today and who knows what they
can accomplish in the future
this month they sent me this eureka box
to make a hand-powered air pump that you
use to blow up balloons
happens to a lot of guys but not to me
i never knew how to tie a balloon there
it goes
oh oops yeah you can learn how to make
giraffes and other balloon animals so
far i've only learned how to do a snake
that um deflates real fast either way it
was really cool to learn about air
pressure
and pneumatic power while putting
together this pump
so kiwi co wants kids to be fearless
innovators and design projects to help
them develop that muscle
and you can get 50 off your first month
of any crate by going to kiwico.com
new rockstars linked below and in the
description yet still
if marvel is telling us geniuses at work
can it which is fully in their right to
do
why would they go to the trouble to open
this series with a reconfigured
in-game sequence if they didn't want us
to think about how this would all fit
into
endgame's timeline logic which brings me
to theory three the one i think is
probably the most accurate the tva
is full of and that is the point
see when loki presses her rent slayer
gives circular logic
well perhaps i should speak to these
time keepers
gods to gods i'm sorry but they're quite
busy
oh they are what are they doing
dictating the proper flow of time
i see right and then what do you do
dictate the proper flow of time
according to their dictations yeah like
loki we are given little reason to trust
the authority of the time keepers
according to missed minutes they
interfered with an ancient multiversal
war to smush the timelines into one
sacred timeline but by doing so
they picked winners and losers and they
set up this draconian system
where those who step off their destined
path even by accident
like showing up late for work are
dragged through this traumatic legal
process
and really their whole mythology was
cooked up by the tva's in-house
propaganda department so loki's right to
consider this absurd
it's broken these guys are not the good
guys and while loki may have conceded
his stone quest
he still has no respect for the tva's
rule of law and will betray them as soon
as he can
especially if all of this is just coming
from ren slayer's dictations
of the timekeeper's dictations and these
beings are weirdly enshrined all over
the place but we never really see them
in the flesh
in fact these marching orders for what
is and is not in the sacred timeline
could just all be
made up on the fly coming from some old
man behind the curtain
and now things are unraveling for the
tva they're getting desperate they're
making mistakes
because they are facing a crisis some
loki variant has been murdering
minutemen and stealing their reset
charges six in the last week according
to u-92 which by the way interesting
that they track their
own time in days and weeks so when
another loki variant l1130 shows up
it makes sense that the tva fears him
and singles him out
discriminates him doesn't really have a
good answer for him because every loki
represents a threat to their
already flawed system now the tva calls
each variant a nexus event
the same term one division used to
describe the scarlet witch because she
is a nexus being in comics who can
transcend reality
and i think that previous era of that
multiversal war was the result of nexus
beings
and now the tva fears another nexus
sorcerer will repeat the historical
cycle
and unravel the sacred timeline back
into a multiverse and they're worried
it's going to be a loki variant but
while their sights are set on variant
loki's they really should be worried
about wanda maximoff upsetting that
balance into a coming multiverse of
madness
support this channel by checking out our
new loki inspired merch options like the
shirt loki out of time
at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
new rockstars for every question you
need answered about loki thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you